[Musique]
mon service a fait son nid sonne oui ces
fiches pour vous et bien beaucoup voilà
j'ai ma femme qui est parti en vacances
oui j'aurais voulu savoir si vous me
dépanner mais certainement ralentir du
festi mais voilà alors un spécial
alimentation est ce que vous affirmez
coup certainement
nous avons tiré des listes y est vous
pouvez nous comment ce passe il commande
par téléphone de tous ces articles même
s'il y en a que vous trouvez pas sur la
liste
vous pouvez les ajouté et nous ferons
cecos également pour vous dites moi vous
êtes un célibataire type
eh bien ma foi de moins de camions s'est
investie par les partis en vacances et
c'est moi c'est un peu la pagaille jeudi
dans la presse qu'un service pour
dépanner le seul en chine ici vous êtes
perdu un célibataire perdu vous avez
beaucoup de problèmes à ses angles on
l'aménagé ce qui semble assez grande
famille comme problème dit à la cuisine
mais pour l'instant la cime fm et le
soir quand même tous les jours en
servant pixels c'est pas drôle a reçu en
tout chez moi et elle avait zappé
s'accumulent égal mais n'a jamais admis
pour sa part ça m'embête
alors là vous venez voir s'il ya une
autre possibilité s'il ya la possibilité
que quelqu'un fasse toutes ces tâches
pour vous et la demande et vous allez
trouver
je veux croire donc on se trouve et vous
voulez pas toucher à l'armoire des
madame pour ne pas la déranger nouveau
souvent mal mais vous vous et moi j'ai
mis 2 reste ne m'intéresse beaucoup
parce que justement vous vous dites je
sais pas trop déranger les armoires lors
si vous pouviez me fournir la lingerie
oui et il ya une chose qui est quand
même très avantageux c'est vous pouvez
apporter votre linge de maison salle de
médecin je vous le redonne immédiatement
puisque nous faisons l'échangé gardant
toujours notre linge propre y attend
peut très bien se mettre mes premières
dites moi il ya peut-être d'autres
problèmes qui peuvent se poser pour un
célibataire il ya peut-être une
baignoire qui fut un robinet qui se
ferme a mûri nous présente tous les
dépannages monsieur ébéniste électricien
dans les deux heures ne vous des pagnes
ou alors dans les 24 heures dans la
mesure de notre petit vos noms comme ne
faut pas nous prendre des mesures que
vous n'avez pas d'autres problèmes
personnels alors je me sais qui je suis
je suis un bouton power
elle se compose de recoudre oui c'est à
votre vessie si oui ce soir une jeune
figurante immédiatement vous l'avez
vêtements ou alors c'est très bien alors
bonne nouvelle le candidat fait pour
vous
si vous permettez monsieur g point de
votre main qu'on a c'est un oui oui
alors messieurs de monsieur du mobile
je suis addict indiscrètes oui oui du
java votre adresse monsieur taposeea
location nous sommes 30 35 16
[Musique]